silver medal honors this year go to
jonathan la nagar with his film
Josephine Josephine and the roach this
is incredibly surreal he's like hiding
behind a bush it's like watching me and
he's gonna tattoo of the title my film
on his leg so um yeah so like you know
everyone else went to thank the academy
for quite an incredible week and I'm
getting very ill and it's their fault
because they woke me up and they
shuttled me off to wonderful places to
talk to cool people so yeah I'm just
going to read off a list now of all the
people I need to think my co-writer Joe
Swanson we wouldn't meet and you know
like watch it Pixar short and drink
coca-cola and you know right crazy stuff
about cockroaches it's weird to think
that that occurred my producer is Damon
stay Josh tape and Kristi hegenberger my
DP Damian ran my casting director ali
sher and my wonderful cast including
someone very dear to my heart at Jenna
algun who's extraordinarily talented
actress and Jerry white jr. and circus
really it's Jaleski sorry and my Roach
who is created by the incredible Lena's
to Bowie my ad Cassandra chattery my
production designer ouch owie my editor
x Kruger my sound designer Bethenny
sparks my visual effects supervisor Tony
D'Agostino and my composure Daniel
Daniel James Chan and my incredible us a
mentor Michael Taylor who you know just
believed in this from the beginning
which is incredible and my wonderful
parents James and Dorothy la nagar all
my Kickstarter backers and you know it's
about it roaches unite and as a favor to
me sparrow roaches life because why not
you